a look at some of the texans 2018 season
resulted in a division championship the
arrow was pointing up then came that
home game in the postseason against the
colts and yet again the texans don't
show up in the playoffs the teams in
their division well other than maybe the
titans i don't know where the titans
really are they should have a feeling
they may have a surprise for us in store
but this is about the texans the jaguars
and the cults are going to be better
this is going to take everything the
texans can manage to win that division
again chris and i look at what they've
done this off season job number one
improve the offensive line do you think
they've done it yeah i do i mean you
know they get a veteran guy and matt
khalil who comes around from carolina
who of course was underwhelming there uh
he can add some depth they decided to go
with the young guy route that's really
the big thing titus howard in the first
round second round max sharping those
are tackles so they're a little unproven
they're both extremely talented love
both guys coming out in the draft but i
don't know if you're gonna be able to
count on them to be day one starters the
big thing is they just got to stay
healthy up front they got really got the
injury bug bad last year on the
offensive line that led to some of the
issues as far as pass protection of
course desean watson has to do a better
job uh with keeping his body safe too
and avoiding some of those big hits that
you and i talked about all year last
year i still look at the texans and
think they're going to be an incredibly
good team my big question about them uh
and we saw in the in the wild card game
mike was their past defense their past
defense struggled last year and they got
gashed by andrew luck and company in the
first half of that game in the wild card
round and yeah they lose a kareem
jackson they lost a tyrone honey badger
matthew you know so how do the new guys
like a bradley roby rolani johnson who
got drafted to sean gibson in free
agency are they going to be able to
improve uh that defensive secondary i
think that's the big question because it
wasn't just talent it was also scheme
that got exposed a lot in houston to led
to some of those big plays so those are
some of my big questions
they got to figure out what they're
going to do with your davey and clowny
[ __ ] determine long term he's under the
franchise tag they have a deadline of
july 15 to sign a long-term deal no
indication they're making any progress
there and you know the big thing is
desean watson he he is the franchise
quarterback he is the guy who can take
this team
if he's healthy and if he has enough
help around him yeah as far as it ever
would want to go but 62 sacks last year
and more importantly chris
133
hits on desean watson who is not a big
thick human he is skin i don't want to
say skinny yeah but he he's not he's not
built to withstand that kind of abuse
and it's amazing to me and it's
impressive to me that he managed to play
the whole season but you know we saw
what happened to him as a rookie he had
that torn acl where it went in practice
but he told us after the fact that he
think it had he thought it happened to
him in the game against the seahawks
where he got twisted up a little bit
look it's going to happen again the
guy's fearless but it's going to happen
again it's the same concern we have with
the carson wentz you have to know how to
avoid taking those hits because it's
basic physics you take enough hits
something is going to go and you're not
going to be able to play and then it's
going to be whoever their backup
quarterback is and i don't know who
their backup quarterback is and i don't
think i want to know who their backup
quarterback is no i i don't think any of
us want to know and in fact as you're
saying that i'm going wait who the heck
is their backup quarterback i got to
represent brandon
they got aj mccarron in there this off
season that's who i oh that'll help yeah
well that'll help exactly right so yeah
desean watson is certainly got to learn
that i mean yeah there's just too many
hits and especially forget the hits that
he can't do anything about it is when he
tucks the ball away there was too many
times last year whether it was the
dallas game or whatever it may be where
he got crushed and it was just
unnecessary and let's not forget he had
to take a car ride to jacksonville he
couldn't fly with the team because he
had discomfort in his chest and his
lungs and everything like that so he's
dancing a fine line there i still think
this houston texans team is very good i
do think the offense needs to improve
too though one hey when it's just always
a deandre hopkins show they gotta show
me another weapon in the past game if
will fuller's not there and he's had a
hard time staying healthy as you and i
both know you know
it just becomes all about hopkins and if
hopkins can't make it happen with desean
watson then the offense kind of
struggles so you know they need to find
another weapon to spread the ball around
a little bit and two i do think the
offense has to grow too it's a little
predictable as far as the x's and o's
department you got a guy like desean
watson who can do just about anything
athletically at the quarterback position
i'd like to see them do more on that
side of the ball
i had forgotten about the bus ride to
jacksonville because they thought he may
have to take a bus ride did denver for
the home or for the road game after uh
the the one in jacksonville and uh look
the guy's fearless and and i got to give
him credit for that but you also have to
be smart you have to do everything you
can to be available for your team and
eventually you're not going to be able
to go if you take that kind of a
pounding it's on the texan to give him
better protection but it's also on the
quarterback to better avoid the hits and
that was one of the things that
impressed me about him as a rookie he
seemed to have that instinct to weave
through traffic and avoid taking the big
hits but you know what if you just don't
have any protection you're behind the
line of scrimmage it's unavoidable chris
you're going to get hit you're going to
get hurt and i think that's the big
concern for the texans can they keep
watson on the field and can they allow
him to be healthy because surely if he's
100 he's not taking a bus ride to
jacksonville he's going to play better
yeah no
exactly right and you know
it's it's it's he's gonna learn to give
up on plays sometimes you know he's so
special and so talented that even when
he's got he's behind the line of
scrimmage and somebody's holding his
jersey he just never gives up he always
thinks there's a way he can make a throw
or spin out of it and break the tackle
and make something more happen and he's
just got to gauge that line to where
okay i can make that happen or this
isn't worth it let me go down and not
get my head knocked off by some defender
who loves hitting quarterbacks
the quarterback depth chart in houston
deshaun watson aj mccarron joe webb
and that's it so stay healthy deshawn
watts
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports